[music]
2 places
[applause]
[music]
nothing there is no light there is no information there is no
vacuum we just don’t know anything at all
[music]
if the first days of the war the victims were measured in
tens, today they are already measured in
hundreds and probably after two days they
will be measured unfortunately  thousand
products
[music] a
bunch we forgot mustaches that there were 3 of me
to work at the monetary corridor
Russian troops never arrived and
lagoon
[music]
after
two corpses of a woman and a man lie on the ointment for three days
and then someone is not there  it can be seen from the
locals they wrapped up
talking between the dance
[music]
we will see if there is something left there
whole from our house